i just interviewed archie yates recently
he's doing the homeland reboot have you
heard about it have you seen the trailer
no i have not so i have nothing to say
about the house am i what an interview
terrible terrible come on now
so obviously we saw a brother of yours
bring that iconic role of home alone to
life might we ever see uh yeah time or
two and it's a home along or whatever
yeah i think it's called home alone guys
might we ever see one of your siblings
cross over into the succession world
that would be cool wouldn't it yeah yeah
that would be game for that that would
be cool okay
why wouldn't i be game that sounds like
fun
if we don't beef up soon i think we end
up someone's lunch
when will your father die uh with due
respect no no obviously hugely looking
forward to my father dying i cannot
imagine anyone else playing roman roy
you were meant to play this role and
allegedly or not even allegedly i read
recently that you knew that you wanted
to play this role because you you
submitted your tape to uh i guess the
show runner saying this is what i want
to yeah yeah yeah cousin greg is that
right yeah they send to me for greg
which i was just very very wrong for uh
that was a bold move on your part i just
asked like here's the one i want to
audition for they said i guess the
response was we're not auditioning for
romans just yet so i just went and did
it anyway i just like picked three
scenes read it and sent it in such a
roman movie i guess so maybe that was
what it was the show has received so
much praise so many accolades from folks
like the emmys from critics from fans
does that provide extra pressure when
you're entering into your third season
of the show no i don't really feel that
kind of pressure i don't really pay
attention all that stuff i'm not really
like an on the internet kind of person
so when i when i'm told
that there's responses or whatever i
just don't really you know when the emmy
knobs are coming in yeah that one i hear
and they go like that okay that's that's
a sign the other side is when people on
the street are yelling you at me that's
that's a sign like oh people are
watching it
billboards just saying yeah but there's
billboards for all sorts of shows like i
was walking down the street with my
two-year-old daughter the other day and
it was they went out in the morning and
i saw oh they put up the succession
poster like on our corner and she's
pushing her little like mini stroller
and i said i go zisu who's that who's
that she goes dada
just keeps pushing she doesn't give a sh
she doesn't
your little one congrats on the newest
today thank you yeah eight weeks old oh
my god how are you standing right now uh
you know
that's a good question i had two glasses
of champagne that helps i got to ask you
where we're going to see roman and jerry
where's your relationship going to go
yeah yeah watch it yeah
watch it